WINNIPEG FOR BOSTON WHICH WAS KD
SPIRIT.
AND THE BEST OF COLE CAUFIELD IS
OUT FRONT ANDS BRAD MARCHAND
IN THE HEART OF IT ALL.
>> Garry: BRAD MARCHAND WAS ON
THE SIDE OF THE PIL NICE POISE D
TO GET IT OUT OF THE AIR,
PEZZA
AND A COUPLE D IN TODAY.HE BOX T
GO AS ERIK HAULA ON IT IN FRONT
FOR MARCHAND.
A BLOCKER SAVERCHAND COMES OUT E
PEAND.
GOT IT DOWN WITH A LOOSENT FOR
WIDEMAN.
WIDEMAN WITH A SHOT. HOLSON BROD
ON THE SAME DAY.
HERE'S COYLE WITH AND HAULA WILO
THE LINE.
JAJA LINE TO
MIKE REILLY.
WAY AND
REILLY WAS THERE.
NOW IT'S MARCHAND WHACK FOR
BOSTON TO DEB HERE IN FRONT
OF THE NET AS PEZZETTA WAS
AND THAT JOLTED HIM PRETTY GOOD.
AND HOW ABOUT THISG
YOUR HEAD DOWN AND SOMEONE
WILL COME BACK TO CENTRE.
CARLO ON IT AGAIN.
DOTTED ACROSS FOR FREDERIC.
BROKEN UP BY
HAND.
THAT LED TO A PRETTY GOOD
SCORING CRST ONE ALLEN OH.
SHORT-HANDED, ARMIA SCORES! SHIE
THEY'RE RIGHT AS JOJO WILL BREAT
UP.
FLIPS IT HIGH IN
COREY SCHUENEMAN WILL LIFT IT IN
TO THE BRUIN
JONATHAN DROUIN TRYING TO PLAY T
HERE IS TAYLOR HALL TRYING TO
GET IT ACROSS.
BUT WIDEMAN GOT HIS
GRZELCYK ON FOR DEBRUSK.
GOES BACK FOR GRZELCYK.
GR
FREEZE THAT UP WITH A COUPLE OF
BRUINS ALL AROUND HIM.
AND HE DID NOT BLEED A REBOUND
MARCHAND.
GIVE AND GO.
TEES IT UP!
PUT IT OFF THROUGH.
BLOCKED BY SAVARD.
MARCHAND KNOCKED IT DOWN OUT OF
THE AIR.
NICK SUZUKI WILL TAKE OFF
CHARLIE COYLE DOWN THE
HE TAKES A DEEPER DOWNPITLICK GO
THAT'S THERE.
GRZELCYK WITH HALL AND MARCHANDE
WING.
ERIK H